What are the potentials for performance loss
when you have a microkernel based operating system
design? Well, the main source of potential
performance loss would occur at border crossings as
we have seen before, and border crossings
have both an explicit cost associated with it
as well as an implicit cost associated with it. The explicit cost is the fact
that from an application which is at a particular protection level, namely the
user level protection level of the processor
architecture, you are slipping into the microkernel,
and, which is at a different privilege level. That is the explicit cost in
border crossing. And in order to accomplish
a particular service that an application has
requested, the service has actually provided by several
processes above the Micro Kernal, and therefore, there are
boarder crossings involved going from the application to
the Micro Kernal to the particular service you're talking
about Let's say a file system service. And
on top of that, a system service like file
system may have to consult other services such
as a storage module or a memory management module,
in order to complete the requested service
of the application. In which case there are
going to be protected procedure calls that are
going to be executed. Between services that are
part of the operating system. And these
protected the procedure calls, because they are going
across address spaces, is going to be more expensive
than simple or normal procedure calls. And typically,
protected procedure calls can be as expensive
as 100 x, 100 times. Normal procedure
calls and this is coming up because of the fact that each of these services
in a micro-kernel based design is assumed
to be implemented in its own address base
to protect the integrity of each of
these system services. Now why are protector procedure
calls that much more expensive than normal
procedure calls. This is where the implicit Cost
of border crossings comes in. Whether the border
crossing happens when we go from the user
address piece into the kernel address piece
or between one hardware address piece representing a
paticular system service. To the hardware address space
of another system service. And that implicit cost
is a fact that we're losing locality, both in terms of address translations
contained in the TLB, as well as the contents of the cache that the processor
uses in order to access memory. All of those add up. In making protective
procedure calls or going between user space
and kernel space, that much more expensive.